that such health actor mejía with his
informative watch for today thursday june 24
a teenager is dead after an
apparent love triangle dispute
this happened to the northwest of the valley at about
10 pm in a residence
located near him with durango los
Officials said that when they arrived at
the scene a woman jumped from a balcony
while saying that her ex-husband was
inside with their three children She also
said that his ex-girlfriend had been
shot Police detained the ex-husband
however they could not
immediately identify who  it was that he shot no one
else was injured
if you have not yet received your vaccine and
you want information about the different
clinics that offer
you we will tell you that today they will open one of the
fire station number 103 and
inside the trinity united church starting
at 8 in the  tomorrow two more clinics
will open today and tomorrow inside karzai
tonight and mules that jim wright both
will be available from 2 30 to 6
pm  rde
this is not all since carmen field
will also offer vaccinations during
the las vegas lights game tomorrow
you can receive one between 4 38 30 at
night if you register in advance
through the health district page
you can receive two free tickets
for  any game played at home
the lights are offering a
free entry without registration
now take a look at the weather conditions
another day with temperatures
below 100 degrees for today Thursday
we will still have clouds with a slight chance
of storms for the weekend
temperatures  exceeding 100 degrees
102 for tomorrow Friday have a nice
newspaper your hector mejía and this was his
brief start informative in Spanish
[Music]